hey David won't medicare-for-all kill
jobs this is a really loaded question
and I'm glad to have the opportunity to
talk about it there's this imagery of
killing jobs that is a very political
imagery to be quite honest with you
because the reality is that all the time
governments federal government state
governments departments of the
government whoever all the time
decisions are being made that have an
economic impact and they have an
employment impact sometimes we're
talking about thousands we're talking
about a thousand new jobs but we lose
200 but there's some economic gain or
some social gain from that change so
number one we've got to get away from
this imagery of quote killing jobs
because all the time as a country
evolves decisions are made that create
jobs and that eliminate jobs they cause
firings they cause layoffs they create
new industries etc what we have to
understand is that a lot of those jobs
that exist in the medical field right
now which would be unnecessary and thus
would disappear under a medicare-for-all
system are not jobs that are actually
providing for the greater good what I
mean by that is if you consider medical
ensure health insurance fraud
investigators medical billing and coding
experts on the insurance side medical
billing and coding experts on the
hospital side by the way not all of them
would go away under single-payer under
many single-payer systems they remained
all of this bureaucracy plus the profit
that is implicit in the system that
doesn't lead to better health outcomes
it doesn't lead to lower costs it's
simply yes providing work to the people
that are in those jobs and it is work
that is being paid for at the expense of
people who are buying availing
themselves of health care services so
would some of those things be eliminated
if Medicare for all were to be passed
yeah some of them would the economy
would have to adjust in history this has
happened many many times I give this
example often and I think
applies here think back to the
development of the automobile the
automobile was a much more efficient
means of transportation than horse and
buggy carriages or whatever you call
them there were people who said this is
going to eliminate the jobs of the
drivers I don't know what they were
called of the horse buggies would that
be a reasonable reason not or not to
allow cars to be developed or to prevent
the development of automobiles of course
not
ultimately those individuals no longer
were in demand in that role of horse
buggy drivers they were reintegrated
into the workplace in other ways some of
them probably suffered long-term
unemployment that's true but we need to
stop falling for this idea that any
policy that will result in any job loss
is unacceptable in fact it's actually a
very sort of center-right idea I mean
there's this infamous video of Milton
Friedman arguing with some college kid
where the college kid says shouldn't
there have been consequences for some
car company that had a car that was
dangerous and Milton Friedman said okay
well hold on so there was a negative
consequence from the car from some kind
of negligence how much should that car
company have paid to fix that problem if
the car costs 10 grand
and it cost them 10 grand to fix their
problem should they have been forced to
do it
what about should they have paid
$100,000 to fix a problem on a $10,000
car at a certain point you get to this
realization that there are going to be
negative consequences to doing the right
thing and whether you run the Milton
Friedman side of that or not it doesn't
actually matter the point is every
single day decisions are being made
policy is being affected where some jobs
are lost there is some economic cost it
has to be accepted in a country of 340
million people anytime you make any kind
of change there will be people who gain
and people who lose right now the losers
are people who can't afford to pay for
care people who get substandard care
people who are going bankrupt because of
medical bills and those who gain are the
for-profit insurance companies the
elected officials
that perpetuate the status quo in
exchange for donations and whatever else
yes some jobs won't be necessary under
Medicare for all the net benefit is
gigantic and that or some system like it
is still the right thing even though
there will be jobs that will no longer
be necessary and we just have to accept
that and not fall for the right wing
talking point that it will kill jobs and
by the way that is a that is an on to
the defensive talking point when the
right goes to Medicare for all will kill
jobs they've often already conceded some
of the benefits of just such a system in
terms of access to care and in reducing
cost that's why they retreat to it and
it is a very very weak counterpoint to
some kind of non profit system the likes
of which many countries have already
employed let me know what you think we
have a great bonus show for you today
become a member or a patron to get
instant access at WWJ in pokémon comm or
at patreon.com slash david pakman show